I'm really proud of you for going on this
trip. You're going to have so much fun.
Similar to the first film, similar to
Jurassic Park, that was a movie that was designed to
be seen in the theater.
Because there's so much spectacle involved. We
try to design an experience that
was going to be conducive to large
format. I love big scope and I love the
big movies but I also want those movies to
have an intimacy and a sense of humanity
to them
bringing that feeling to this was my
absolute number one priority. You know
the IMAX experience specifically in this,
it's a pretty
stunning experience, you really do feel the
difference
I think this is the kind of movie that
needs to be seen
in a theater you'll be able to watch
this on two-dimensional
you know media through the course your
life forever on download it or watching TV
or DVD or Blu ray or something but
seeing this in the theater on a 60 foot
widescreen in IMAX
and feeling the dinosaurs in your lap I
think it's the beauty of a movie like this
You just can't feel the largeness of it
when you're watching it say
on your phone or even on your TV. You
just don't feel it.
But when you're sitting in the theatre
watching in IMAX. I mean the sound
makes you physically vibrate. Watching
the movie
is like going on some kind of theme park ride.
Because we wanted so many moments to
feel like a nature film you know the
mosasaurus, all these
you know Jacques Cousteau kinda moments. And I think the IMAX experience
specifically in this
in addition to the 3D is the way to go.
I think people can expect
a blast when they see this in theatres
and particularly in IMAX.
I think people are going to  lose their minds.